[Music]
yeah your most accurate weather now
forecast we sherry off today we start
with this look at allegion stadium we
were just talking about those raiders
who
definitely need to get off the schneid
we need to get the wind to die down it
is still whipping out there
as you're getting ready to walk the dog
or go for a jog or whatever make sure
you're properly bundled up officially 46
degrees
but we wanted to check in on your
neighborhoods here's what's going on out
there
nobody's in the 30s just yet but
alegante you're close at 40 same with
centennial hills
of course kyle cannon a lot colder at 22
and the wind definitely whipping up
there
everybody else in the 40s wind speeds
all over town between
20 and 30 miles an hour you know it gets
down to the teens up in northern nevada
that's exactly what's going on ely
caliente
you're at 48 boulder city you're at 45
obviously cooler in cedar city at 24. so
yesterday we made 57
but with the wind whipping it's just not
as cold
tonight as it was last night and it's
also not going to be quite as warm
but 55 is going to be close to normal
our current temperature is the low so
far this morning
once again we're just watching clouds
coming and going it's a different story
in the nation's midsection because
everybody who's got family and friends
on the east coast you need to let them
know
that that is a strong nor'easter brewing
right now over nebraska and kansas
we're talking upwards of 18 inches of
snow
maybe not as far south as washington dc
but certainly up there by new york
philly
and into parts of massachusetts we could
sure use some rain here
it's not in the seven day forecast going
to be in the mid to upper 50s with
clouds coming and going
and breezes coming and going as well by
the way this is the last full week of
fall we welcome
winter on monday